It's a very high-risk situation, we're taking all the precautions we can, and we're just trying to
stay strong mentally about the whole thing. Justin Barber may look like a doctor about to rush out and treat
COVID-19 patients at a moment's notice, but he's actually a biomedical technician, someone who fixes
medical devices. He works out of a hospital in Houston, Texas. Normally you know we glove up and
we take care of business on-site, but now we have to wear masks 100% of the time.
When we go into a room we put on a fresh set of gloves and then when we leave we take those clothes off,
have to wash our hands, sanitize, and then you know sometimes re-glove, just to leave.
It's the job that's gotten dangerous during a global pandemic. If one of us gets sick then obviously
multiple technicians in a room somebody
else is probably gonna get sick,
and you could take down a whole hospital just by taking down your biomed staff.
Barber has been preparing for the worst of COVID-19 in the next month by making sure
ventilators and other medical equipment
are in working order.
I can honestly tell you that we don't have service manuals for a lot of stuff. Some of it is intuition,
and other things we rely on forums. Barber and other biomed technicians have been trading information
on Reddit, Facebook, and websites like Med Wrench and Dot Med for years.
It's a big network of BioMed's that will get online and will present the problem to the rest of the world and
we'll see if somebody has an answer, which
usually somebody does thankfully.
Medical device manufacturers have tried to stop this decentralized information sharing
to maintain full control over their
products manufacturers have fought
against DIY repair services in court as
well so biomedical technicians have had
to think creatively especially in a
pandemic because one broken machine
could be the difference between life and
death for a patient what has been
happening over time is the medical
device companies are employing some of
the same tactics that we've seen Appl
use where they'll say well we'll sell it
to you but we're not going to let you
service it we want to be the ones to
service it Kyle wins is the founder and
CEO of iFixit a third-party repair
company for consumer electronics many
companies are good guys and they provide
the information that vile meds many
companies do not manufacturers
frequently claim manuals and the
information in them belong to them and
not hospitals it's the results of
broadly written copyright laws written
throughout the 1990s to protect the
music and film industry from pirates
that were taking their work and sharing
it first through bootleg VCR tapes and
then online why buy when you can get
your music for free on Napster but in
the 2000 software began to get
integrated into phones household items
cars farming equipment and medical
devices to manufacturers tried to make
it so they were the only ones who could
repair consumer devices it's not just
service manuals but it's also sometimes
the service utilities which you know you
connect the laptop to the device to get
it to calibrate or to read the error
codes we have problems even with special
tools because sometimes you need a
special tool to accomplish a special
task and apart there's some
manufacturers that won't even sell us
parts its proprietary and we have no
access to it inter Frank's hospital
workshop comm so Frank is a hero of the
modern world he is a German guy who is a
biomedical service technician in
Tanzania and what he was finding was the
equipment that was donated that ended up
in Africa there was no access to the
manufacturer a service supply chain
Medtronic's not going to send a service
technician to Tanzania so he had to
maintain it himself and he was just
struggling with finding this information
too so I'm gonna set up a website and
I'm gonna organize all this in the
central fashion for years Frank posted
manuals service information and wrote
about how the equipment worked I would
say from my experience the most
comprehensive most used resource for
medical service information then Frank
started getting takedown requests from
manufacturers we used to rely on Frank's
quite a bit but since the manufacturers
started placing takedown requests a lot
of our resources on there have you know
become incomplete there's a lot of dead
links most service technicians are
relying on the information that they
don't have direct access to the
manufacturer for so there's all kinds of
you know oh it's a secret but non-public
forums where they're swapping this
information because it's almost faster
to go on the forum and ask someone for a
service manual than it is to go and find
the authorized way they get it a right
to repair movement has fought for years
to change u.s. copyright law or passed
state-level laws so biomedical
technicians as well as the general
public could fix their own devices but
medical device companies fought back
with letters to lawmakers saying write
to repair laws could endanger the lives
of patients if devices were fixed in
parlez by untrained personnel the trade
association Advan ed which represents
medical device companies has even
lobbied the Food and Drug Administration
to step in and regulate third party
device repairs but after an assessment
by the FDA in 2018 the administration
set objective evidence indicates third
party entities provide high quality safe
and effective servicing of medical
devices it seems like the larger and
more entrenched on monopolistic these
companies are the more likely they are
to be saying we don't want the hospitals
fixing these things instead they want to
send out their own service technician in
an emergency there's no time to send a
broken respirator back to the
manufacturer or wait on a service call
which leaves on-site technicians like
barber to keep hospital equipment
working so I'm going to show you around
my office right here he has his own
YouTube channel for sharing information
with other BioMed's some of the best
resources are when nurses or nurse
training managers they'll post videos on
YouTube showing how they set up and run
a device so you can you can go on
YouTube and even see how to replace an
ACL you know if you wanted any type of
surgery you can go on YouTube and you
can see how does that surgery happen and
that's one of my coolest resources
because I get to see how the users use
the device so you learn the clinical
aspect of it plus the mechanical aspect
I fix it recently announced an
initiative to begin collecting service
manuals and information about medical
devices on its website I've been really
surprised that there isn't good
system-wide information about what kind
of equipment is out there if you want to
help us we we have thousands of PDFs
that we're organizing and so it should
be nice if we could as a community come
together and say well maybe we don't
know how to fix this equipment ourselves
but we can organize files
so let us as a society come together and
organize files and create the
centralized resource so that when the
bio meds do need it it's in a nicely
easy to find place barber is already
working overtime to deal with the impact
that Cova 19 is having on his hospitals
equipment and the worst may be yet to
come right now
even even our maintenance cycles are
getting tighter and tighter because we
don't have access to the equipment it's
currently saving somebody's life so
that's that's definitely going to be an
issue especially in about a month you
know as these hours click down the
amount of you
we're gonna start to see problems where
we're not going to be able to get to the
equipment until it fails so we're just
praying that this passes by and we're
gonna do all right